[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
up the record we talk about whatever we
want anthony's
[Applause]
clapping i want coffee god damn please
ah how long have you been going without
coffee i had coffee like two days ago
when we went to get donuts
we're not talking about that i thought
you were wrong some coffee what
because yesterday he comes in he's like
okay i really want a coffee but i'm not
gonna drink coffee and then right now
so wait so then that means the day
before yesterday you drink coffee i had
coffee less than a handful of times
within a month why are you doing this on
and off coffee thing well caffeine
i was drinking coffee so much that it
was giving me crazy ass anxiety remember
we talked about this with nadeem and
nadine was like it gives his heart crazy
he's also on steroids oh okay no i don't
i don't know i don't know for me when i
did the whole eczema thing i just
detoxed out of
everything so um it was kind of nice
because the the coffee thing
was basically giving me the jitters like
crazy
how much coffee do you consume maybe
it's not how much it's what kind
i like the vietnamese crack
that'll do it or it's also how it
affects them too because we got a guy at
our gym stand he's our our main trainer
um and he can't even drink a full cup
because i think he's a naturally anxious
person
so if he drinks more than half a cup
he'll have straight up panic attacks
that doesn't make sense to me because if
you're naturally
anxious or i don't know about anxious
but like hyper though that coffee
actually does the opposite effect it
makes you sleep i don't know if he's
hyper
but he's naturally that happened to me
when i was a kid like i i was diagnosed
with like add
yeah my adhds in particular and
i would [ __ ] drink coffee and it
would make me go to sleep you know him
it's like uh
he's not high energy it's just he like
it's easy for him to get pessimistic and
easy for him to like
just think crazy whatever so like it
gives him actual panic attack for me
it boosts my energy too much to where
now i can control like my sleep better
but then
if i drink my cafe soda in the morning
and then i get my cup of black coffee
and then lunch time
oh she got like a triple threat
situation yeah maybe in the afternoon
you know get some tea whatever it's just
a lot of caffeine throughout the day
and sometimes like you know when you
zone out on caffeine
that zone out feels so good that's the
best you lose
track of time right and then yeah and
then like i don't know
it was it was depriving my sleep and
just my whole thing my energy was
difficult to control so i didn't realize
that until
after i went through the detox and then
during the whole month i didn't even
want it or need it the first week was
crazy though i had a crazy headache i
was going like
yeah it's so hard i only consume one cup
of coffee a day
and you went through the withdrawal
still and if i skip that one cup
for one day like at the end of that day
or like the next day i'm like
i have a pounding headache i'm like it's
only one cup
yeah i get crazy withdrawals and it
hurts like [ __ ] for me it was like a
a whole week of just scratching headache
whatever
and then all went away and i was like
this feels great let me just
slowly introduce like regular things
dude we're little
i mean i won't include you but i'm a
little [ __ ] because every time i want
to be a little [ __ ]
no whatever you want must be a little
bit no because what i'm trying to get at
is that every time
we try to detox from coffee and like we
try
really hard we're like okay [ __ ] okay
we're gonna have these
pounding headaches these migraines for
the next few days let's [ __ ] get
through it
but then we give up you get pounding
headaches migraines are the worst though
like you can't when you can't fight like
internal pain that's like
you're at your limit you know what i
mean but you got to drink like hell of
water get mad sleep and then like just
take like
18 advil but the best way to quit is not
even knowing that you're quitting
because i just naturally did it on
that's kind of what happens to me where
yeah you forget to drink it like why do
i not until my head is like
literally throbbing and you're like oh
wait i forgot to drink coffee today
like i've i feel like if i don't drink
coffee i'll just be extra tired
and i'm just like oh god why am i so
tired today oh yeah i didn't drink
coffee
and i could go like a whole week without
drinking coffee i'm just
gonna pass it to here left my coffee
over there you started thinking about
coffee i was like i'm craving coffee how
much coffee do you guys drink though
a lot for caffeine yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
probably like six seven hundred
milligrams i do it to be productive how
much is it in a normal cup
like a cupcake so a cup maybe half maybe
like a hundred
this is a cold brew what's in a cold
brew i don't know maybe a hundred you
know what i miss
about coffee is the taste
i love the [ __ ] taste man whether
it's black coffee
espresso yeah i mean i'll even drink uh
decaf
like with a meal because it feels like
yeah it tastes different i've never had
decaf no it doesn't taste the same
yeah yeah but there's no decaf stuff
they're still kind of yeah those are
still caffeine though i don't know
it's like very little it's like 25 or
something it's like so it's negligible
it's like the same as like
there's probably more like chocolate
starts like negligible there's caffeine
in chocolate
what dark chocolate is a little bit of
caffeine
you just want to taste it it's not going
to make you feel anything oh damn it
yeah like for me i think uh my the
half-life of caffeine
is really short for me because i think
it sounds like for joe like his
half-life could be like
12 16 18 hours where that's why it
affects the sleep
if i drink like three shots of espresso
i'm like
like 30 minutes and then it's gone
really good yeah you're telling me when
you drink
matcha you put like eight of the scoops
that's
insane matcha to detox
from other stuff but then the amount of
mulch you can do
well because i'll take it so like my the
mod what i like about the
matcha caffeine it doesn't have the like
that
it's more of like a
nice it's a different height because we
got l-theanine baby
yeah so far when i'm like doing like uh
after my
after i'm up already and so i usually
take my matcha
after lunch because in the morning i
need something like
wake up [ __ ] i'm like oh [ __ ]
and then
after i eat lunch i just need something
that's like aha time to do some work
you know i don't need someone to [ __ ]
strangle me see that's what i missed the
meth feeling
yeah this right here this feeling is
real brigade pre-workout for me yeah
right
when i say well i could down a cold
route and i'll be like i'll be i'm ready
for work
i can [ __ ] do half a pre-workout and
it's like my skin is about to flare off
and i'm like you better get to work boy
[Laughter]
i went through like three weeks of super
low energy
but then i was able to get never as
caffeine but then i was ever to i was
able to get the hype back on my own oh
that's dope
yeah but it took a long time though yeah
was that a conscious thing though what
do you mean were you like looking for it
where you're like i'm avoiding this and
i'm like gonna bring the hype in right
now yeah there's something in the cheeks
i had to work on it like i had to work
on my
brain i guess but also i think the brain
was dependent
on that jump start from the chemical
versus like the
the inner like if i just got up in the
morning i was like all right i'm gonna
get my coffee and i'm gonna [ __ ] run
and then and it made you run that much
better because it just
boom you know but then when you're
running like first thing you wake up
even if you slept well
it's a slow grind till you get to that
hype well it's slower
for me if you're used to using coffee
interesting yeah
well like if i came into jk news right i
really depended on
coffee to just jump start me in the
morning and i'm like wow
i noticed is that if i sleep earlier
wake up earlier
and then i'm working out doing all that
[ __ ] and then i'm already awake by the
time i'm here
then i'm way more alert and i don't need
it yeah
i don't know how come you want it today
just to taste because you're broke i
miss the taste you smell coffee right
now yeah i smell it
it's stronger when you cracked open that
can it made me smell it i'm all
coffee yeah you all heard that
we all we all heard his coffee monster
come out yeah i think i
i love the taste dude is the the the
vietnamese coffee too
i would drink that without any caffeine
like if it didn't have caffeine i would
drink that [ __ ] three times a day
it's so good i don't even think it's
just the caffeine that's like sugar
yeah the condensed milk oh yeah the
vietnamese coffee is so good
sweetness how about like pre-workout
like that won't
give you the same like high that you
miss from coffee i think it's the
vietnamese crack
i need that taste too that's the best
like that [ __ ] battery acid table oh
i love it i know it's everything that's
bad for you like the caffeine content
the uh the condensed milk i know because
you can't even drink milk
you can't handle normal milk but this is
condensable because i don't feel this
way about
like a starbucks or every like like
black coffee or even pre-workout
pre-workout actually scares me
dude i feel like my heart and i only
take a quarter like not even a scoop
or not even half it's like a quarter of
a scoop and i feel my heart like about
to [ __ ]
pump out of my body i have dangerous
levels of confidence on pre-workout
that's why i don't want to do it oh you
do like really heavy weight
i'm just like i don't feel nothing and
then i'm like keep going and i'm like
you know what
i think i have super powers and i'm like
watch me hold my breath for 10 minutes
or like i'll do something crazy
don't watch me is that a normal reaction
to pre-workout
no i mean i think that's why people like
it because like like for me you know
when you drink like like if i get a
doughnut i
almost have to get a coffee right
because for some reason the donut
doesn't taste the same
even though the donuts itself is the
same the donut without the coffee
doesn't taste the same
so even with like on a run like let's
say if i'm gonna go on a short run
i don't technically need the caffeine i
can still complete it i don't it's not
hard for me but then
running on caffeine the quality it makes
it more fun
yeah it's just like any cardio on
caffeine it makes it so much more fun
yeah it's the quality of it it's like
going on a imagine you guys are going on
a candlelit dinner and then
no wine and they're like boring this
date kind of sucks
you know it's just it's just like i
don't know just yeah yeah i get it
each and each caffeine has its own thing
for me i might have a vietnamese coffee
thing for me i have a special time for
that like i'm not gonna be taking
[ __ ] pre-workout on jk news that's
gonna [ __ ] me up
you should do that we should all do it
one day
we should post mates some coffee right
now
because this video is brought to you by
postmates baby
no but honestly i [ __ ] love postmates
so much because
for me at home especially with the kid
now like you know we're all working at
home so we're working
but then you also got this crazy ass
[ __ ] running around so it's
really hard to
manage time and then so sometimes you
know like i think when you're used to
living by yourself
you're like i'm not hungry and then so
you could just keep going about your day
and i'll wait till i get hungry to eat
lunch and that's like 3 p.m but you
can't be doing that with the kid you're
gonna
you're gonna [ __ ] his ass up yep so you
have to stick them to a schedule
so i have little reminders on my phone
at 11 30 i ordered lunch
for the little monster is what i call
them and so you post mates a kid's meal
well i post mates like whatever and i
know he loves like miso soup and stuff
yeah so i always post mates from like a
local japanese place
with like miso soup and i get like
chicken like teriyaki chicken i make a
little stew
for him you just mix it all together he
loves it he loves like uh
you know like the sumo like chunk he
loves like a
[ __ ] he's kind of like me like
whenever you put rice in miso soup we
call that cat food really he loves cat
food
with chicken because you i mean you get
the leftovers right like when you have
dinner and then there's miso
soup and rice you just put it together
you put it outside and the cats come eat
it
so pet food looks like the wet pet food
sometimes you see like chunks of meat
and like some sort of like
rice or like flour i don't know what it
is i don't eat cat food sometimes yeah
it looks good no he loves it he if he
eats that he always does this thing
he claps and then he does two thumbs up
but his hands are all small
go like this so for a limited time
postmates is giving our listeners 100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days so to start your free
deliveries download the app and use the
code off the record
that's off the record for 100 of free
delivery credit with no minimum purchase
of your first seven days when you
download the postmates ad
anything you need anytime you need it
postmates it
i think i might break my deal for myself
and get
i'm gonna post made some cafe suit out a
two-day detox
day and a half well i i would say that
uh i went for a whole month
and then i sporadically drank coffee i
haven't had any vietnamese coffee too
it's always just been like weaker you
should get a vietnamese one you order
i'll get one right now i'm serious i
love vietnamese coffee if you order one
through postmates order me one too okay
me too
the people that do vietnamese coffee
right i like it when they do uh the ice
there's big blocks and the crushed one
oh you know the crop the crushed one it
has like
an even um melting so it it it slowly
dilutes it but then the big one kind of
keeps it cold yeah cause i like the
combination of the butter i don't even
need it right now because i'm pretty
hyped
but i just want to taste i could always
use more that's true i'm pretty hyped
well you want some coffee though like
flavored he wants to be an amazing
vietnamese coffee
too i'm just gonna break my [ __ ] first
five days
it's been five it's five more days till
next month the best vietnamese coffees
come from the restaurants that have like
minimum like around like three two and a
half three stars out
really really well that's four or five
stuff anybody in these restaurants like
five stars out of five
probably not owned by vietnamese person
probably one by like a smart korean
person
and then like you know it because
vietnamese people
really good food terrible service so
service is always knocked down so you if
you see like two and a half stars
i don't think it's a bad restaurant i
think it's good food i think it's just
terrible service
and that's gonna be really good food i
feel like i've noticed that's only
vietnamese restaurants in vietnamese
neighborhoods are like that oh that's
the one you look for
but if you go to a vietnamese restaurant
in like a white neighborhood it's like
the nicest people ever i'm like who
who are you i've never met vietnamese
people like this because they're trying
to cater to the white people
oh they're like extra extra nice
sellouts
or or their ambassadors to the culture
you know they're we're also proud of
them but i want to know what the
family meeting was like was it like guys
something's not right they keep talking
[ __ ] about a restaurant
but the food's great and they're like
maybe we're doing something wrong here
no and then somebody was like nah [ __ ]
them
and then they just kept going about
their way and that's why their ratings
are mediocre no no
but you said in the white neighborhoods
it's better right neighborhoods because
there's a white guy saying
hey buddy you didn't seat me down when i
walked in
and in the white neighborhoods they
upcharged more right so it's like 30
30 40 more
it's like yeah 40 percent less flavors
way more black
healthier less msg
there's a lot less fish sauce it's less
it is more bland i've ordered
from like three or four other
restaurants around me if i live in like
more white neighborhood now
they all suck ass yeah dude you want the
tasty stuff
like real tasty vietnamese like fun like
they're like the ladies are bringing out
with their thumb
in the bowl you know when you're and the
bowl is dark
the broth is dark it's not clear and
they got they got like the audacity to
like
they're just like i'm gonna protect you
so i'll wear like a latex glove but then
i'll just cut the thumb
so the whole glove's gone so they know
that their thumb's in the soup and they
know that you know that they're thumbs
in the city
i haven't seen that leave the fly
it's not even like a thimble it's like a
latex glove that's like still rolling
over because it was cut
yeah they call it finger condoms wow
condoms
that is so [ __ ] true some soup why
has everyone
did everyone go to the same restaurant
because everyone's seen that thumb
that's where they've been trained at the
same time it's like it's like that thumb
was made with seasoning
and if you don't get the thumb in it
you're not gonna get the flavorful one
with the thumb inside i've seen it
multiple times it [ __ ] blew my mind
there's probably like a [ __ ] competition
where you drink it
no thumb no no you don't want to go like
that
oh [ __ ] that's it right there
it's missing the thumb what if you put
four thumbs in it
it's like really good oh yeah this is
how they mix it this is how you make fun
that's why i massage too man
have you guys been to vietnam yeah
absolutely the motherland man
you know what blew my mind um is
how much more like fashion forward
everyone was there
compared to here well what i mean by
that is like they're way less
conservative
conservative dressing like i saw like
than us of our parents age
tattooed up like super skimpy clothes
like
everywhere like you go to like a regular
cafe like
like moms are in booty shorts or
something or like
oh yeah yeah that's because they can't
afford the rest of the shorts
and it's hard or like she has like a big
ass eagle right here and it's not even a
gangster mom like she's fashionable cool
yeah and i was like
oh crap cause i don't know maybe because
out here
there's more catholic vietnamese and
conservative so they're super like
yeah like traditional and whatever but
when i was out there i was like damn
there's so many
cool ass looking people i was shocked
like yeah and i thought whenever i
thought of vietnam too i thought it was
like
jungle in the past jungle you know when
you see like paris by night and all that
[ __ ] like the styles look like kind of
very traditional yeah but then everyone
there the young people whatever
they look like [ __ ] fresh and like
regular and i was like what the [ __ ]
right now vietnam is super hip i'll be
admitted you know
when you talk about things like fashion
or or just forward thinking and a lot of
things like that
uh as a vietnamese person as well i feel
like there were a lot of countries in
southeast asia that were like really
owning a lot of like the business market
the fashion market whether it be like
japan and korea have always been like
very very strong powerhouses in those
departments but i feel like right now
vietnam's about to be like a super power
to the world you know what i mean and
i'm like
everything that's going on there is
freaking fresh it is it's crazy
everything's building and the variety of
coffee there
there's so many kinds like they out here
you just think cafe said that
but out there they got like coffee
coconut slush
like all kinds of egg drop like they're
just so that's the north vietnamese one
yeah the egg drop coffee
super bomb what is that it's like coffee
foam so they use the egg yolk
and then they kind of whip it and so
like
you know like when you get a root beer
float right yeah and then the the froth
part
so imagine a thick froth as the whole
drink
yeah so apparently i think it was
because of the war and they didn't have
dairy
so they're like oh what are we gonna use
so they tried using eggs instead and it
worked
and it's tough it's like i can make at
home i'm gonna try that just drop an egg
into the coffee and just stir it
it's a very wartime drink and it's like
a warm wartime drink
um that sounds good though the whole egg
or just like the egg white
i think it's the egg white yeah i think
it's the egg white is it egg white if
you use the yolk you can't uh you can't
foam at the same time oh
oh so so it what forgot it's called so
it's a war drink yeah it is a wartime
drink
from the war old schoolers drinking it
only the north vietnamese people though
that were
only in the north vietnam that's
probably why because out here south
vietnam culture huh yeah so you don't
really see that out here is there
south vietnam culture now in vietnam or
is it has it kind of just no south is
still
like it's still very separate in terms
of culture and
even like like attitudes like people in
the south
a lot of people who live in this house
still really don't like the people in
the north is your family from the north
my family i have a lot of family in the
south yeah my father's from the south
we're the ghettos
so you guys got like vietnamese
confederate flags
no it's not like vietnamese confederate
it's the other way around
it's like the freedom for freedom so
it's the yellow flag with the three red
stripes
you're not going to find a flag with a
star on it in like a little saigon
that's true yeah but at the same time
you're not going to find that flag in
vietnam
yeah because they think because you guys
are the traders huh yeah you'll just
disappear
yeah because they're like your trader
yeah you know what tripped me out though
is in europe i met a ton of northerners
in the czech republic because their
history
um was different like after the vietnam
war
because they were homies with the czech
republic because they were under the
ussr at the time
they were all communists right so there
was a work exchange program
and so the biggest ethnic group in the
czech republic right now is like
hundreds of thousands of vietnamese
people and they have their own little
like westminster kind of area they have
i went to like a paris by night thing
there and i was like what the [ __ ]
what you went to a parent in czech
republic it was kind of like a like a
little of
scripture it's embarrassed by night it's
a it's a vietnamese variety show
like like the vietnamese variety showed
up but it was like whatever
he meant but they were all descendants
of northerners but they're westernized
it was [ __ ] mind-blowing dude
because i grew up around southerners
granted though the czech republic in
general is mind-blowing
in general it's a crazy place it's
mind-blowing about there it's got
a lot of beautiful people beyond that
like the czech republic has like
prague as the capital right beautiful
city it's
super beautiful but it's also like the
place of like satan's bible and it's
like
what you never heard about this no
there's like illuminati like triangles
on top of structures and stuff but you
can't google anything about it
um and it's like satan's bible is there
there's like no religion that's like
sanctioned there there's like um
women there girls there at age 14 are
legally allowed to have sex
whoa oh yeah there's a lot of brothels
there too yeah wow
it's a beautiful place it's just
different it's weird because um
the whole place feels like a communist
place like because it used to be the
buildings look very communist
and then you see the mcdonald's sign on
it yeah
that's [ __ ] weird well it's it's like
you know how communist
like russia the apartments and things
there was a style like a building style
that we weren't
it's not like we still see like the that
like that logo the hammer and like the
no they took all those communist things
down but the buildings are still there
but now it's like uh western
corporations
so you see like forever 21 and all these
things as you're walking down they're
like
famous but at like the very top of the
buildings you like zoom in with your
phone like
triple 10x zoom i don't know you just
see like these little gold statues of
like triangles and like upside down
angels and stuff
it's like really weird
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you